bonsoir ce lorient philippot le vice
président du front national est l'invité
de preuves par 3 bonsoir et merci d'être
présent à ce rendez-vous de public sénat
avec l' agence france-presse
trois grandes questions comme chaque
semaine une question par partie première
question est ce que vous êtes de mauvais
perdants dans les régions en multipliant
on l'a vu les incidents lors des
nouvelles assemblées régionales alors
que l'emploi sans peut-il ouvre la voie
à une collaboration entre l'exécutif et
les présidents de droite
on l'a vu aujourd'hui à matignon comme à
l'élysée deuxième question florian
philippot est ce que vous avez perdu
votre meilleur ennemi
avec le départ de christiane taubira et
vous direz à mickaël szames est ce si
vous êtes sûr de pouvoir revendiquer une
victoire idéologique avec la déchéance
de nationalité qui est de plus en plus
contesté à à gauche au parti socialiste
mais également on le voit à droite
enfin troisième question le front
national va-t-il changer de ligne
économique un virage libéral voire pro
euros c'était aller un peu loin tous les
cas c'est ce qui sera décidé ce week-end
lors d'un séminaire que réunit votre
parti et vous répondrais sur ce sujet à
guillaume daudin de l' agence france
presse mais avant de vous poser la
première question sur les régions donc
présente aujourd'hui on l'a vu avec
manuel valls et françois hollande votre
réaction au vote unanime des élus
européens à strasbourg contre la levée
de votre immunité parlementaire
le procès donc voulu par le qatar contre
vous n'aura pas lieu vous maintenez que
cet état du golfe finance le terrorisme
en tout cas il l'a financé il faudrait
savoir si le finance toujours il ya des
choses manifestement extrêmement louche
dans l'entourage de ce pays et y compris
de l'arabie saoudite
ce n'est pas à moi de le dire mais je
suis heureux que la liberté d'expression
et de critique d'un élu d'un
parlementaire et même d'un citoyen en
général dans une démocratie comme la
france ait pu être préservée je trouve
je vous le dis très clairement et
réaffirmée par le parlement européen
oui mais je le trouve honteux que la
france l'état français par la signature
mais mme taubira qui avait transmis
cette demande de levée d'immunité
admission ça ne voulait pas vraiment
dire
toujours un ministre a toujours la
liberté de ne pas signer et que là que
la lave et la glace assez dur exactement
que la france ait pu accepter cette
procédure judiciaire qui est
incompréhensible la plupart des autres
pays européens est simplement dans la
plupart les autres démocraties en dit
long sur notre état de soumission par
rapport au qatar alors je finirai bien
il y aura pas de procès heureusement
c'est donc vous vous maintenez vos
propos mais le qatar dit que c'est de la
diffamation
on peut le dire ce qu'ils veulent qu'ils
souffrent la critique et surtout qu'il
change de politique
le qatar est une infâme dictature qui ne
respectent pas les femmes qui ne
respectent pas les minorités qui a un
comportement extrêmement louche
vis-à-vis du fondamentalisme islamiste
ce qui m'évite danse est une évidence
mais là au lieu de critiquer et
d'intimider doit se réformer en
profondeur ou doit disparaître de nos
relations diplomatiques
en tout cas on ne rend pas le chemin
puisque manuel valls à gré avec la
france soit moins soumise et que les
dirigeants français soient moins soumis
à ce confetti à ce petit pays
vous parlez d'une soumission manuel
valls lui a dit récemment c'était il ya
quelques mois il a dit sa conviction il
ne doute pas que le qatar lutte contre
le terrorisme oui il faro moi je leur
amène olive de vos confrères monsieur
péan et madame ratinier à d'autres
enquêtes rapport écrit par les services
français américains et qui sont beaucoup
plus dubitatif et surtout au delà même
du financement du terrorisme et vous
mettra un point d'interrogation à
leucate et armes étaient un poil je ne
sais d'ailleurs il ya eu du financement
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas en tout cas
sur le reste il faudrait et j'ai demandé
une commission d'enquêté parlementaire
en y intégrant le front national via par
exemple les députés européens mais sur
les financements du qatar dans notre
pays
financement prise de participation dans
les grandes entreprises stratégie on va
pas lui reprocher ses massifs et rien à
voir ici entre dénoncé le financement du
terrorisme et l'activité économique en
france lorient philippon ses massifs les
prises de participation dans des
entreprises stratégiques
c'est pas le premier indicateur
s'éloigne de la france comment la france
peut-elle accepter cela les financements
religieux puis lancement de certaines
mosquées
qu'est ce qui s'y passe qu'est ce qui
s'y dit et puis évidemment les liens
entre le qatar et le personnel politique
institutionnelle et économique français
mais ce que tout est clair dans cette
affaire est quoi pourquoi l'ensemble des
dirigeants gouvernementaux français sont
ils à plat ventre devant le qatar dès
qu'on parle d'eux
ce pays que se passe-t-il pourquoi point
d'interrogation j'aimerais qu'on
éclaircisse là où tu as déjà question je
trouve un peu revenir jouer vous et la
russie tous ces gens vous dira on déjà
on ne peut pas comparer les pays nous ne
sommes pas aux responsabilités moi je
suis tout à fait capable d'avoir un
langage extrêmement critique sur la rive
sur la russie si vous le souhaitez je
dis simplement que la france doit
rééquilibrer ses relations
internationales ne soient pas soumises à
washington c'est pour cela que nous
souhaitons un vrai qu'il ya de rage mon
art notamment vers la russie mais pas
que vous avez d'autres monarchies du
golfe dans le viseur à part le catr je
pense qu'il ya deux pays qui sont
reconnus comme étant louche vis-à-vis du
fondamentalisme c'est le qatar et
l'arabie saoudite avec deux pays ont
fait beaucoup de pays qui sont infâmes
dictature et sur lesquels on n'entend
jamais recruté par exemple avec la
rabine ont généré on voit quand même nos
ministres à plat ventre devant l'émir du
qatar devant le roi d'arabie saoudite on
ne comprend pas pourquoi alors que
pareille démontre il ya des contrats
créés à des contrats mais ils ont dit
qu'ils en oublient leur moral
ils sont gagnants beaucoup plus
pointilleux vis-à-vis d'autres pays qui
ne sont pas des démocraties parfaite
c'est moi qu'on peut le dire mais qui ne
sont pas les dictatures aussi infâme que
ces deux pays aient ce qu'il faut
renoncer aux contrats commerciaux alors
avec le qatar et l'arabie saoudite
à quand il engage la france sur sa
parole sur sa politique étrangère oui
s'il s'agit d'acheter notre diplomatique
des dollars des pétrodollars
certainement pas finir la france doit
avoir une parole libre une diplomatie
livres et s'il s'agit d'entreprises
stratégiques que ce soit le qatar ou un
autre pays je souhaite qu'on fasse
valoir le patriotisme économique de
toute façon
florian philippot la question se pose
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs c'est le sujet de
la réunion de rome avec une cinquantaine
d'états de l'ouverture d'un troisième
front contre le groupe etat islamique en
libye est ce que vous y soyez favorable
c'est-à-dire aller réparer à les
combattre la progression à les réparer
calé après l'éclairage et vannerie
d'instituer un sanctuaire
oui oui c'est à dire aller réparer les
conséquences de l'intervention
désastreuse de monsieur sarkozy et de sa
muse bernard henri lévy en 2011 et que
le front national était le seul à avoir
des noirs c'est dans la classe politique
française envers l'institution les
jeunes il faut quand même faut quand
même ramené toujours les choses pour si
l'on comprend rien d'accord on en est là
qui a détruit l'état libyen c'est
sarkozy qui a mis à la place les
djihadistes et aujourd'hui le verrou
vers l'europe
c'est aussi la politique de sarkozy
soutenue par le ps avec ont fait
aujourd'hui il faut y aller peut-être
des frappes oui s'il le faut
même si on n'a pas le choix si on n'a
pas le choix vous on ira donc réparé et
encore une fois ce qu'on a fait nous
mêmes et si on n'a pas le choix je veux
pas pour la politique du pire
certainement pas d'intervention sol
peut-être des frappes
il faudra qu'on en discute qu'on en
débatte tous et peut-être qu'on se pose
la question d'un deuxième porte avions
français
moi je suis très favorable à ce que nous
ayons deux porte-avions et on voit que
dans cette affaire ça pourrait être
extrêmement utile une grande puissance
une grande puissance diplomatique et
militaire comme la france devrait avoir
deux porte avions
par ailleurs ce serait un investissement
extrêmement rentable ça ferait
travailler nos chantiers ce après
travailler nos ingénieurs nos ouvriers
et ça permettrait d'aller vers
l'innovation je pense qu'il ya que des
avantages
est ce que vous craignez que les
terroristes dissimule certains des leurs
parmi les migrants qui quittent on le
sait en masse les côtes libyennes
je le crains d'autant plus que nous nous
prévenons sur ce sujet là depuis des
mois et des mois et même bien avant les
attentats du 13 novembre alors à
l'époque on nous disait qu'on fantasme
et qu'on veut jouer sur les peurs on
surfait jure je ne sais quoi
il se trouve que parmi les les kamikazes
du 13 novembre il y avait des gens
infiltré dans la route des migrants donc
nous avions raison il faut arrêter et
c'est de ce flux de migrants toute la
france retrouve des frontières
nationales et qu'elle a red à l'heure et
politique de la passoire quête schengen
vous avez vu ce qui se passe en suède le
pays a assuré qu'il allait renvoyer 50%
des migrants qui sont arrivés sur son
sol en un an
ça fait quand même 80 mille réfugiés la
moitié de ceux qui sont venus donc les
renvoyer même entre charter est ce que
c'est un modèle à suivre avant d'arrêter
d'en faire venir d'autres de façon il va
falloir renvoyer ceux qui sont là le but
n'est pas le renvoi pour le renvoi ils
trouvent ya des gens qui sont arrivés en
masse où il va falloir notamment parce
qu'ils sont entrés en clandestinité ou
parce qu'on estime que le système
d'asile est saturé alors voyez ceux qui
sont là à 50% n'auront pas droit à
l'asile vous pensez que c'est une
proportion qui met sa sérénité entrées
d'immeubles en france ont le droit à la
ville c'est un tiers je crois des
demandeurs d'asile donc 50 % la suède
reste extrêmement généreuse c'est un
exemple d'ailleurs incompréhensible vu
les drames qu'a connue ce pays
on l'a su qu'ils avaient été cachés plus
ou moins par les autorités par la police
et les médias notamment je parle
d'agression sexuelle de valeur leur
masse comme marley du drame
oui ce sont des drames alors il ya et je
voulais vous parler
attendez sur ce sujet là et en ce moment
continue savait il avait un petit peu
arrêté avant les régionales pendant deux
trois semaines
de nouveau on voit les migrants arrivés
dans les villages les communes les
villes françaises
j'ai des exemples aujourd'hui à verdun
on apprend que des migrants vont arriver
un peu partout et sans l'avis la
consultation des habitants des
populations et souvent même des mères
vous parlez de draps ou sur l'ailé
politique n'est pas viable
aller à parler notre âme les naufrages
1/2 grand en mer egée sont pratiquement
1 survient plus de 300 enfants sont
morts ces quatre derniers mois
que dites vous pour rompre avec cette
indifférence quasi générale qu'elle
n'est il pas sûr qu'il ait une
indifférence je pense que la soeur parle
pas très peu de temps mais un peu quand
on peut on peut faire couler des larmes
de crocodile est considéré qu'il faut
donc accueilli entre aigle au nez par
leurs différents mais personne n'est
indifférent à cela mais on peut qu'aller
il ya deux solutions soit on dit il faut
donc accueillir tout le monde par
grandeur d'âme par générosité n'aura été
vous allez susciter des flux de plus en
plus important et donc vous aurez de
plus en plus de noyade ou deux personnes
qui se retrouveront et tout fait dans
des camions ou je ne sais quoi
soit vous dites il faut qu'il ya des
camps là bas sur place les camps de
réfugiés
quitte à ce qu'on finance davantage
l'onu le scrc mais c'est le clan de
l'europe oui non mais non le plan de
l'europe c'est d'en faire venir quatre
millions en europe millions cette année
en relation deux autres spots comme on
dit ne te le plan de la numérologue
c'est pas de les laisser là bas madame
merkel on a fait venir un lagon marqué
qu'elle avait réalisé un petit peu soit
position de son jugement je regarde moi
des chiffres chaque semaine il en
arrivait énormément encore en allemagne
or il n'ya plus de frontières au sein de
l'union européenne dont ils peuvent
venir en france qu'ils soient là bas et
puis qu'on re stabilise la région bien
sûr par une action diplomatique
intelligente contre l'état islamique on
n'en prend pas tout à fait le chemin
alors dans l'actualité et là je reviens
à la question du départ faire un filippo
il y a donc les présidents de région
aujourd'hui à matignon et à l'elysée
pour une action commune pour l'emploi à
travers la formation donc manuel valls
n'exclut pas d'ailleurs d'accorder de
nouveaux pouvoirs en ce sens aux
exécutifs
nous avons rencontré l'ensemble des
présidents de région et je me suis
exprimé juste avant de venir ici à
l'assemblée nationale avec le président
des régions de france
ce philippe richert sur le fait que lui
étions en train d'élaborer pour les
prochains jours pour les prochaines
semaines un document conjoint qui donne
davantage de responsabilités aux régions
et dans le cadre des lois actuelles
c'est-à-dire de la luano de voir s'il
faut aller plus loin dans le cadre d'une
nouvelle législation qui permette aux
régions d'assumer et d'assurer
pleinement leurs responsabilités dans le
domaine du développement économique de
la formation de l'accompagnement des
chômeurs et de l'apprentissage et j'ai
dis encore une fois que nous devions
être à l'écouté de l'ensemble des
régions car au delà des couleurs
politiques
nous avions une responsabilité c'est de
tout faire pour le cheval alors que
pensez vous de cette main tendue de deux
côtés d'ailleurs cette responsabilité
partagée ça va dans le bon sens c'est
une main tendue c'est une valse
permanente façon je ne modère ses
lointains go et ils sont si vous voulez
monsieur richard puisqu'il en parle
c'est le président de ces régionales où
je suis élue je reprenne je préside le
principal groupe d'opposition en alsace
champagne-ardennes lorraine sur richard
dans son discours d'investiture en
quelque sorte avec l'art et sa flamme à
manuel valls
donc ils considèrent que le parti
socialiste fait partie de sa majorité la
main mais de voir comment ça se passe il
ya aucune différence
on l'a on a passé six heures à voter
lors de la dernière session pas une fois
où peut-être une fois il s'est abstenu
et pas une fois le groupe de gauche soit
disant d'opposition a voté contre ou ses
oies émis une proposition faire un
amendement ou quoi que ce soit donc
évidemment qu'ils sont ensemble ils
partagent tout en étant même fait élire
ensemble la cause commune c'est l'emploi
wilf un désastre commun surtout on sort
de 30 ans de cogestion ump s ou rps
aujourd'hui dans les régions et au
niveau national surtout on voit que le
chômage n'a jamais été aussi élevé
la pauvreté aussi donc leur désastre est
commun alors c'est pourquoi je voudrais
favorable à tout nouveau transfert de
compétences de toute façon avant toute
nouvelle décentralisation
je reprends la cerise et philippe séguin
le regretter quand il était président de
la cour des comptes
la décentralisation est structurellement
coûteuse alors c'est pour ça que vous
êtes nous le mur d'un jour 10 days
j'ai lu ça coûte cher c'est pour ça que
vous avez l'air d'être des mauvais
perdants là dans tous les conseillers du
attention aux travaux et maria des
invectives des incidents et intel
deux élus du front national qui traitent
les autres de niakoués par exemple il
s'est traité lui même en disant on n'est
pas des bons il s'est traité lui-même il
est demandé à ce que désormais il la
possible le mot procédure le monde
arrive l'éviter il aurait pu éviter le
mot oui mais bien sûr mais si vous
voulez moi je suis à la tête et tu lis
dans nos groupes ça se passe comme cela
je suis à la tête d'un groupe
extrêmement responsable j'ai fait voter
la dernière fois deux amendements à
l'unanimité dans monde dans mon
assemblée
j'ai fait par exemple traduire en
langage des signes les séances du
conseil régional c'est nous qui l'avons
proposé ça a été en même temps que votre
programme l'unanimité pas le grand
barouf le mot avait été vite mais on l
appariement barouf
non ce n'est pas le grand barça on est
là on est là vigilant pour faire
respecter nos engagements vis-à-vis de
nos sept millions d'électeurs et comptez
pas sur nous pour être des paillassons
comme le parti socialiste vis-à-vis de
l'ump où l'ump vis-à-vis du parti
socialiste selon qui est qui et qui
l'opposition la majorité
nous sommes là intransigeant et en même
temps constructif par exemple le
président henri certes dans les conseil
régional a donné sans consultation aux
169 élus des iphone si soyez du coût de
700 euros plus l'abonnement à tous les
élus vous l'avez garder non nous nos 46
élus on est là on les a rendus et les
soldats donner aussi des détails les
amarres il a donné des ipad va vous
l'avais gardé comme dans toutes les
régions de france
mais là vous l'avez garder à la c'est un
instrument travail laisse que les
documents de son nom mais les documents
ne sont plus imprimé à le document de
son pré imprimés donc nous avons
l'instrument de travail
ok mais vous avez gardé à vous avez
rendu l'autre enfin je vous devriez
apprécier monsieur grossiord qu'on est
rendu l'iphone on est les seuls à
l'avoir fait bon voilà on est les seuls
à avoir fait écouter 700 euros fait
l'addition 700 euros x 169 plus les
abonnements mensuels donc libéré par
ailleurs j'aurais aimé puisque vous
parlez de la tablette j'aurais
effectivement qu'elles soient de
fabrication française avec mais si on
avait été consultée en nous relate le
dire on n'a même pas été consultés bon
allez on parle toujours de l'emploi avec
l'idée qu'ils progressent au
gouvernement pour vous dire gaspillage
gaspillage gaspillage on l'a dit dans
nos campagnes les dévoyer la première
décision qu'ils prennent c'est dilapider
l'argent public
d'accord qu'un exemple philippe richert
telle nuit
ce fait de réaliser cinq cent mille
euros d'économie ou cinq au mans avec
l'ademe et dématérialisation que vous
évoquez on verra alors l'idée progresse
par ailleurs récent sur l'emploi d'une
dégressivité des allocations chômage
fasse d'abord au déficit abyssal de
l'assedic l'idée avait été lancée ici
même à votre place l'as far le
secrétaire d'état chargé des relations
avec le parlement et jean marie le guen
on écoute autant il est extrêmement
difficile de diminuer les aides aux
chômeurs dans une période où le chômage
est encore très élevé et en même temps
c'est bien que à la fois un peu pour des
raisons financières dont vous parliez
mais aussi pour mobiliser plus de moyens
sur la formation des chômeurs
il est assez vraisemblable qu'il faut un
petit peu changé les paramètres de notre
assurance chauvin rice alors changer les
paramètres à aller jusqu'à la
dégressivité des allocations cercle il
renonce ont-ils jamais tentée d'ailleurs
il renonce à lutter contre le chômage
donc ils vont lutter contre les chômeurs
bon cette dégressivité elle a existé en
france entre 1900 et 2000 arguments with
les arguments c'est leur droit mais
c'est pour le paquet sur la formation et
déjà être être plus incitatif même si ça
n'avait pas fonctionné
une expérience qu'elle durait dix ans 92
2001 en france ça n'a eu aucun effet ça
a été éprouvée par des études je crois
de l'insee qui ont démontré que ça
n'avait pas eu d'impact sur l'endroit où
vous êtes pour le virer du coc 1
non mais on est nous pour une vraie
politique de l'emploi on pense pas qu'il
faille taper sur les chômeurs on pense
pas que la solution ce soit de lutter
contre les chômeurs mais de lutter
contre le chômage où il ya des fraudeurs
mais il faut lutter de manière générale
beaucoup plus activement contre la
fraude c'est une évidence mais moi je
sais par le bon grain de l'ivraie je
veux pas mettre tout le monde dans le
même sac parce que l'immense majorité
des chômeurs s'ils n'ont pas de boulot
c'est simplement qu'à pas de boulot et
qu'ils ont cherche et quand il ya 6
millions
le quasiment de chômeurs aujourd'hui en
france c'est parce que la situation est
terrible que notre pays est largement
désindustrialisé qu'à passer en
investissements dans l'innovation
capacity l'on tient aux pme et aux tpe
nation assedic vous incitez les
syndicats à faire barrage à la fois au
gouvernement et au medef qui prône
également cette mesure dit le
gouvernement doit enlever ses oeillères
et le idéologique
et changer complètement de politique
pour lutter pour l'emploi notamment en
sortant des dogmes européen qui nous
désindustrialise massivement alors qu'il
nous empêche d'aider les petits qui nous
empêche de faire du patriotisme
économique et qui nous plombe
il ya un personnage qui refait parler de
monsieur lui terrorisé on a tout essayé
contre le chômage
moi je suis obligé de dire on n'a rien
essayé contre le chômage on tourne en
rond sur des mesures est toujours les
mêmes pour essayer de baisser les
statistiques du chômage depuis 25 ans ça
ne fonctionne pas mais il continue parce
qu'il ya des sujets qui ne peuvent pas
l'aborder par idéologie reviendra dans
la dernière interview accordée à
guillaume daudin sur le programme
économique du front national qui en
débat par ailleurs je le disais tout à
l'heure il ya un personnage qui revient
dans l'actualité c'est bernard tapie en
fait jamais été très mal d'actualité
en tous les cas il est saisi l'a dit
récemment dans une interview au jdd par
une ambition politique
il est d ailleurs dit qu'il voulait lui
interdire le chômage des jeunes mais
dans le 'financial en arrivent à penser
dans le 'financial tournage les jeunes
faut interdire le chômage dans le
'financial times' e bernard tapie se
voit en arbitre de la prochaine
présidentielle a même dit il de séduire
une partie de votre électorat et il dit
à 5 ou 6%
c'est moi qui déterminerait le vainqueur
du second tour à ce qu'il est une menace
pour vos jeux c'est là que bernard tapie
avait encore des velléités l'arbitrage
après ce qui lui était arrivé donc on
est obligé de commenter ou on passe à
autre chose on peut passer à autre chose
ça c'est votre commentaire s'il s'arrête
on ira le voir au théâtre à l'elysée
raul castro a été reçu avec les honneurs
la france at elle raison de soutenir
l'évolution même très lentes on peut le
dire de l'île communiste et de demander
avec force la levée de l'embargo
américain
oui il a raison de demander la levée de
cet embargo il faut jamais pénalisé les
populations comme on l'a fait par
exemple en irak
c'était terrible qu'on évolue je m'en
félicite il faut toujours il faut
dialoguer avec les avec les avec les
états la difficulté c'est qu'on le fait
toujours après le coup de sifflet
américain une fois qu'on a eu
l'autorisation aux effets siècle assure
cuba ça sert à réchauffer d'abord avec
les états unis donc la france y va on de
même source sur l'iran on a perdu
beaucoup de contrats parce qu'on avait
interdiction américaine d'y aller une
fois que les etats unis se sont
rapprochés de l'iran il ya eu à bien
aussi on se rapproche l'accord est un
peu dommage la cloche le nucléaire était
international et donc notamment arraché
par la france un sur huit ans oui bien
sûr mais non c'est le suivisme n'est pas
un alignement américain moi je regrette
peu le général de gaulle sur la chine
dans les airs au début des années 60 il
avait une position audacieuse il avait
montré la voie en reconnaissant l'appui
populaire
aujourd'hui on est suivi voilà les
etats-unis disent vous pouvez y aller
donc on y va et pour l'instant on perd
beaucoup de contrats ont pas beaucoup
d'influx ans on perd beaucoup de
rayonnement est ce que vous appelez à
l'évacuation par la force du site du
futur aéroport de notre dame des landes
près de nantes
nous sommes défavorables à cet
investissement cet aéroport
non pas qu'on est défavorable aux
infrastructures en général au contraire
mais pour le coup on avait fait une
étude locale sur cet aéroport qui ne
nous semble pas qui nous a jamais semblé
indispensable ni utile après gérer la
situation locale
ils vont respecter la loi encore une
petite question laurent ruquier a
déclaré dans le supplément de la semaine
dernière sur la télé pourquoi décédé -
bernard tapie ruquier bah oui mais lui
laurent ruquier s'adresse directement à
vous est offert par louis dès le quart
d'heure people bah écoutez moi je si le
front national parce je prends mes
cliques et mes claques et je me tire et
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette prise
de position de hors luzira bye bye
olivier rey buybuy vous n'avez pas le
retenir ou nouveau die je rigole pas et
veut pas mais aiguë pour qui ce
tranquille
j'en veux lui dire fou dégonfler ce cas
là ou pas d'une petite épingle et bouc
une petites épingles c'est souvent ça
fait du bien bon alors deuxième partie
des proches partout à la deuxième
question que va vous poser mille kms de
public sénat dans un sens que vous avez
perdu votre meilleur et demi avec
christiane taubira on verra quel parti
en fait la déchéance de nationalité
trouve de nouveaux opposants
les députés ps qui rechignent et
demandent d'ailleurs aujourd'hui même de
nouvelles garanties pour ne pas créer
des apatrides et puis également les
députés les républicains doute de plus
en plus un peu à l'instar d'alain juppé
qui affirme que c'est un texte
complètement inutile mais écoutons
d'abord christiane taubira quelques
jours à new york 1 devant des étudiants
qui met son souffle oratoire vous allez
nous dire si vous êtes sensibles au
service de la défense des libertés et de
l'égalité
il faut que les citoyens soient égaux
entre eux égaux devant le savoir
ego dans l'accès aux droits égaux dans
l'accès aux soins égaux entre eux
l'égalité n'est pas un slogan l'égalité
est un défi quotidien la puissance
publique est donc indispensable et elle
a des devoirs elle allait devoir qu'elle
doit assumer et en particulier à
l'époque où nous vivons l'époque où nous
vivons est une époque de grands
désordres de grands chaos dans le monde
et assurer l'égalité dans un lieu
suppose ne pas s'accommoder des
inégalités et des injustices y compris
dans des lieux lointains mais tms nous a
rejoint vincent mutel
on a envie de connaître vraiment la
réaction d'être de notre invité vous
pouvez interroger en parle évidemment du
football est une question de forme elle
va vous manquer christiane taubira non
elle ne nous manqueras pas elle ne
manquera pas je le crois aux français
d'après d'ailleurs on a vu dans les
premiers sondages ils sont plus de 80 %
à approuver sa démission
je le comprends parce que même taubira
je juge la mise de la justice a fait une
mauvaise politique elle a poursuivi à la
même accentué le laxisme d'état
ce que je regrette mais elle ya ajouté
un trait supplémentaires qui tient
peut-être à sa personnalité
un sectarisme extrêmement agressif
violent brutal vis-à-vis de l'opposition
démocratique en l'occurrence les
patriotes que nous sommes vous avez là
le duo vous même personnellement remis
républicain vous allez nous moi même
mais peut-être sur la fin du qatar où
vous entendu tout à l'heure oui il a
signé c'est vrai qu'elle a nié la
demande de levée d'immunité n'étaient
pas obligés de faire au delà de ça elle
a eu des propos qui étaient passés à la
veille c'est ainsi que c'est une grande
sectaire madame tugar est très secteur
saturé
je crois beaucoup plus à sa propre
personne que ne l'imaginent à ces femmes
qui voient en elle une autorité morale
ultime alors je pense que par exemple
ces deux derniers mois les a occupés à
faire du marketing et non pas à diriger
son ministère puisqu'elle préparer son
livre en cachette
elle préparait son coup de com elles
préparées cette petite balade en vélo
etc
ça s'appelle être imprésario de sa
propre personne ça ça s'appelle pas être
mise
musa juge chinois il fallait
démissionner le 23 décembre on passe au
fond la cdu font ça d'accord le cri
d'alarmé de hauts magistrats qui
s'alarment que l'autorité judiciaire
soit affaiblie par nos projets notamment
le projet de déchéance
selon vous la justice aujourd'hui est
elle encore la gardienne des libertés
publiques
bell douala est relais en grande partie
heureusement bien sûr pas déconsidérer
l'ensemble de l'institution les
autorités judiciaires simplement d'abord
il y a des problèmes de moyens
indéniablement il suffit de regarder nos
moyens par rapport par habitant par
rapport à nos partenaires
on voit bien qu'on n'est pas au niveau
ça ça pose des problèmes ensuite il ya
eu vraiment une idéologie très fort de
laxisme d'explication psychologique de
lac de la criminalité de la délinquance
qui est juste pas acceptable la justice
elle est là pour juger et elle n'est pas
là pour psychologiser ça ça a été une
tendance qui a été défavorable aux
victimes et je le regrette profondément
et puis nous avons une influence
politique et ça c'est totalement la main
sur le deuxième point parce que
christiane taubira justement dans son
livre notamment il dit qu'il faut avoir
recours aux outils sociologique pour
comprendre par exemple les jeunes
français qui partent pour le jihad et on
sait qu'elles se posent sur ce point à
manuel valls 5 estime qu'il faut arrêter
de trouver des excuses données que des
raisons c'est trouver des excuses dit-il
vous êtes plutôt donc sur la ligne de
manuel valls que l'université que les
chercheurs cherchent bien sûr moi je
suis très favorable à sociologie à tout
le reste
mais quand on est ministre la justice on
a une autre casquette quand on est juge
on est là pour dire la loi et pour
l'appliquer sans faiblesse en comprenant
tout mais sans faiblesse
et c'est cela qui n'est pas fait mais à
date admet mme taubira ça date de bien
avant cette espèce de renversement on
avait le sentiment parfois qu'on était
plus proche du dessin de mon du criminel
que de la victime est insupportable
après je comprends pas le mur des cons
du syndicat de la magistrature il y
avait des têtes de parents de victimes
assassinées considéré comme convoyer et
pas les bourreaux bonjour dire ça sachez
d'urgence je regarde vers les régions et
l'état d'urgence vous vous êtes
favorable cette prolongation d'état
d'urgence moitié personnage conscience
et de la com ça je considère que c'est
la communication est qu'aujourd'hui
c'est la communication de monsieur
hollande et de monsieur valls qu' il n'y
a aucune mesure de fond qui n'est prise
jeudi
rétablissement des frontières nationales
c'est terminé permettre que j'ai décidé
de toujours aller là où on ne pouvait
pas aller jusqu'à présent non mais
restitution réel des effectifs de police
de gendarmerie de douanes d'armes et
s'est pas fait dissolution des centaines
de mosquées radical identifiés par
ministère l'intérieur ça n'est pas fait
voyez des vraies mesures lutter contre
le communautarisme dans les quartiers
réaffirmé la laïcité par tous quelqu'un
est arrivé souvent le terreau de
l'islamisme radical ce n'est pas fait
c'est fait par le reste ce n'est pas
fait pour soi ce n'est pas pas crever
nos forces de l'ordre qu'il faut quand
même aller leur parler pour voir dans
quel état elle se trouve aussi on n'a
pas intérêt non plus à aller elle est
allée à tirer sur la corde de trop parce
qu'elles ne sont pas si nombreuses que
cela et parce qu'on leur demande
beaucoup beaucoup
il faudrait pas que l'état d'urgence
deviennent vigipirate vigipirate on a
instauré ça devait être exceptionnelle
c'était exceptionnel
on l'a instaurée en 95 on voulait on
n'est jamais sorti l'état d'urgence ça
doit être exceptionnelle parce que sinon
ça c'était l'essentiel
voyez comment sortir aujourd'hui à fait
plat aujourd'hui on peut rester ou
sorties banon met à imaginer on vous
demande de trancher
moi je serai parlementaire je voterai
contre et comme annuel dont ils font un
autre choix comme manuel valls dit que
c'est nécessaire jusqu'à ce que la
menace tech soit fini ça lui arrive à
tort mais ça alors ça c'est de ça c'est
inquiétant ça veut dire que ça peut
durer des années et des années
quand est-ce qu'on décidera que la
menace est terminée et puis est-ce que
rappaz une autre forme d'organisations
islamistes qui prendra le relais de
neige puisque on sait qu'avant dèche
toute façon ça n'a pas disparu mais il
ya eu al qaïda qui était la menace
principale et c'est ça ça c'est pas un
critère car on ne peut pas vivre dans
ces conditions là et surtout surtout les
français sont prêts à des efforts mais
il faut que il est le sentiment qui a
une efficacité à côté si les grandes
mesures structurelles de sécurisation du
territoire ne sont pas là je parle des
frontières je parle des effectifs parle
de la lutte contre le fondamentalisme
islamiste
alors on a le sentiment de plus en plus
d'être dans la communication est ce
qu'on est dans un état policier
non non pas dans un état policier on
peut pas dire ça on est dans un état
surtout inefficace vous parlez de
communicative karkwa qui parfois ne
respecte plus les libertés individuelles
ça c'est par exemple le problème de la
loire enseignement où on peut capter vos
conversations vos téléphones vos mails
sans aucune autorisation justement c'est
un look gouvernement veut aller plus
loin beaucoup plus loin en portant sur
ce mois là notamment par exemple se
saisir des données des ordinateurs en
donnant plus de pouvoirs aux policiers
leurs annonces et précisément c'est
qu'on a à la fois et en même temps moins
de liberté et moins de sécurité voyez
sécurité liberté c'est un vieux dilemme
philosophique c'est souvent d'ailleurs
un sujet ça reviendra périodiquement un
sujet de bac philo est ce qu'on peut
concilier sécurité et liberté bon on a
plus de liberté mais moins de sécurité
et inversement à notre gouvernement et
les précédents d'ailleurs ont trouvé la
clé eux c'est moins de sécurité et moins
de liberté donc on est perdant perdant
et bien moi je considère qu'il ya pas
d'antagonisme entre les deux on peut à
la fois avoir plus de liberté et plus de
sécurité à condition que 30 des mesures
efficaces et souvent d'ailleurs la
sécurité rétablie la liberté puisque
quand vous êtes vous sentez sur dans
votre quartier alors vous osé sortir de
chez vous dans la tenue dans laquelle
vous souhaitez être je parle des femmes
notamment
vous pouvez avoir le comportement que
vous voulez vous pouvez avoir les moeurs
et la vie que vous voulez et vous
retrouver la liberté
parce qu'on vous a assuré la sécurité à
côté on va parler de la déchéance de
nationalité
est-ce que vous à titre personnel vous
soyez pour une des chances à tous les
français se posent la question des
apatrides qui est une question
compliquée au niveau
voilà je pense que c'est déjà bien de le
faire cette mesure là pour les
binationaux qui ne soit pas inscrite
millions si le gouvernement me propose
un statut des apatrides et qui me paraît
convaincant on peut alors y réfléchir
vraiment je vais pas de d'opposition de
principe mais mais déjà les binationaux
ce ça me paraît plus simple plus rapide
et presque aussi efficace vous avez vu
que tout a l'air beaucoup plus compliqué
aujourd'hui il ya eu pas mal de
désaccord notamment au sein du parti
socialiste qui demande une réécriture et
qu'on enlève cette mention des
binationaux votre avis selon vous
aujourd'hui le texte n'a pas de majorité
est ce qu'il est voué à l'échec
d'abord l'argument de certains qui
considèrent que les binationaux seraient
stigmatisés par cet article je ne tiens
pas la route
aucun binational ne se sont stigmatisés
tout simplement certains le disent mais
non tout simplement sont des idéologues
qui dit ça tout simplement parce que
heureusement aucun binational ou
quasiment pas heureusement le envisage
de faire des attentats en france dont
personne ne se sente
concerné par cela ça touche ceux qui ont
fait des attentats donc mes scénarios
des apatrides si jamais cet argument
l'idéologie
je ne comprends pas pourquoi ça fait des
semaines ou des mois maintenant qu'on
est sur ce sujet qui est d'une
simplicité biblique qui est approuvé les
grandes grande grande partie des
français mais visiblement on ne trouve
pas il ne crée pas de débat dans la
société française qui créent les débats
parmi des blogs et des bas il faut faire
une différence entre ce qu'a relevé ou
pas de nationalité
c'est la question c'est un c'est un
débat de cocktail de salon ou de houe
d'assemblée dans le dans le décor est
celle de la république mais ça n'est pas
un débat public que je dire les français
pour eux il n'y a pas de sujet on le
fait c'est tout et c'est d'ailleurs une
toute petite mesure par rapport à ce
qu'il faut prendre à côté pour encore
une fois assurer la sécurité des
français on a parlé juste avant ma
question il est plus loin ce que ce
texte vouée à l'échec
mais il ne doit pas être vouée à l'échec
le président n'a pu s'est engagé devant
lé congrès de gras le 15 novembre où le
16 novembre
est ce que ce serait une catastrophe
alors qu'on parle de mesures symboliques
ce serait ça démontrerait que le
président à un public est l'otage une
toute petite minorité d'idéologues
déconnecté des français ce serait
effectivement extrêmement peu rassurant
pour nos compatriotes et qui a raison de
la sécurité de la fermeté des autorités
que répondez-vous par exemple alain
juppé qui aujourd'hui est en déplacement
à alger et qui juge ce texte
complètement inutiles pour combattre le
terrorisme et ont sans le soutien des
députés notamment les républicains de
plus en plus hésitants mais que
répondez-vous à 1 à vue parce que plus
ça traîne plus on va être dans la
politique politicienne
sire que juppé va penser à ces primaires
va penser sur les lecteurs en interne il
va dire qu'est ce que je dois dire pour
essayer de parler d'être repris donc
voit on va rentrer dans la politique
politicienne qui n'est pas au niveau et
on a connu quand même 130 morts le 13
novembre il ya eu les attentats de
charlie avant et de l'hyper cacher on
est l'une vient il faut prendre ce sujet
sérieusement il s'agit pas de faire de
la politique politicienne
donc nous on l'a dit si le principe lié
déchéance de nationalité qui est un
principe que effectivement on porte et
qu'on a porté seul pendant longtemps
eh bien on le votera parce que nous
auront été les grands inspirateurs de
cette affaire et le grand inspirateur
pas de la déchéance de nationalité de
vesle vous prenez les débats il y avait
personne autour de la table à part nous
pour en parler les républicains se sont
mis à me soucier parce que sarkozy en a
parlé dans un discours à grenoble en
juillet 2010
et donc il ne l'a jamais fait sauf qu'il
était président de la république et
qu'il lui restait encore deux ans pour
le faire ce qui prouve bien que sarkozy
et l'ump en général c'est paroles
paroles mais peu d'actions joue pas de
concrétisation
encore une question sur la délinquance
est une des toutes petites mesures ou
alors il faudrait l'étendre en amont de
la réalisation des attentats se serait
déjà plus efficace pour ceux qui vont
s'entraîner de vos propositions syrie en
irak wire au jihad pour tuer en france
et qui sont convaincus par la justice de
faire cela alors une déchéance de
nationalité et qui précédera une
expulsion du territoire national serait
une excellente chose je vous somme est
une phrase du livre de christiane
taubira que peut-être vous allez lire
qui s'appelle murmure à la jeunesse
vous me direz si vous allez lire ou pas
à propos de du terrorisme de la
déchéance elle revient à céder à la
coulée d'angoise qui signe la fin du
politique et de la politique
quelque part elle vous vise quand même
un petit peu c'est ça c'est du taubira
sur cet avantage de l'an du du mauvais
poème que de que de la réflexion
politique revient à céder une coulée
d'angoissé vrai quelque part au sénat
langois son nom vous avez l'impression
que vous savez il s'est passé ce qui
s'est passé en france en 2015 et vous
pouvez pas en vouloir aux français
d'être angoissé devant cette situation
parce qu'objectivement il n'y a pas
grand chose pour les rassurer car il
s'agit pas de vivre dans la peur mais on
ne peut pas reprocher aux français de
considérer qu'ils ne sont pas tout à
fait en sécurité en france qu'il s'est
passé des choses abominables terrible
qui touche quand même beaucoup de monde
et on attend maintenant des réponses on
n'attend pas ce genre de phrases des
réponses concrètes j'en ai attaqué ces
quelques unes voyez par exemple avoir
c'est la belgique la france et la
belgique veulent coopérer sur le
terrorise jeudi la meilleure des
coopérations se serait de remettre une
frontière pas une fermeture à une
frontière un filtre entre la france et
la belgique nice ça ce serait la vraie
coopération efficace mais c'est la seule
qui ne font pas la question qui n'est
pas sur la déchéance ça doit vous
promets l'union des organisations
islamiques de france se réunissent à
lille dimanche
certains orateurs sont dénoncées par les
opposants du bief réputé proche des
frères musulmans
la vigilance promise par le ministre de
l'intérieur était suffisant pour non non
ce n'est pas le premier spa première
fois d'ailleurs qu'on a ce genre de
problème avec des congrès lieu et f et
des personnages absolument pas
recommandable c'est moins qu'on puisse
dire je crois qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
promet la peine de mort pour les
homosexuels c'est ça qui est invité
il faut pas autoriser cette
manifestation pour demander l'adhésion
mais nous on demande bien sûr que cette
manifestation soit pas autorisée qu'on
n'entende pas surtout maintenant ce
genre de propos haineux et insupportable
et qu'il y ait une dissolution du us ça
fait des années qu on la réclame cette
dissolution de l'unef qui sont liées aux
frères musulmans qu une censure
préalable le ministre l'intérieur s'est
refusé dit on va regarder ce qui se
passe là bas on va dans d'autres cas il
a été beaucoup plus rapide et s'est posé
moins de questions alors que là il me
semble qu'il ya quelque chose même de
gravissime qui entraîne la réduction
mais oui mais bien sûr vous allez c'est
pas ce genre de propos qui va faire
avancer le débat
rien fait pour vous avez rappelé tout à
l'heure à l'opposition du front national
à la récente loi sur le renseignement
dans pour laquelle s'était beaucoup
impliqué on s'en souvient jean-jacques
urvoas qui est devenu ministre de la
justice à la place de christiane taubira
un commentaire sur lui oui vous avez
bien mieux que sa prédécesseure je suis
heureux du départ d'anne taubira mais ça
règle pas grand chose et nous
regarderons avec vigilance si monsieur
re as respecte les libertés
individuelles des libertés publiques
parce qu'il n'est pas manifestement un
grand ami des libertés d'après ce qu'il
a fait ce qu'il a fait voter
donc on sera vigilant bien sûr merci
michael troisième partie de preuves par
3 avec guillaume daudin de la fp
troisième question donc le front
national va-t-il changer de ligne
économique c'est sur quoi pourrait
déboucher dit on le séminaire qui va se
tenir à huis clos d'ailleurs le week-end
prochain
un ajustement rendu nécessaire
apparemment par l'absence de victoire
aux dernières élections malgré un score
à 40 %
écoutez l'analyse du politologue pascal
perrineau rencontrer tout à l'heure par
contre un calme et le front national
rentrer dans une mer qui ait l'air de la
préparation de l'élection présidentielle
il veut mettre toutes les chances de son
côté parce qu'il s'aperçoit qu'il y a
encore un plafond de verre à sa
progression on l'a très bien vu au
second tour des départementales on l'a
très bien vu au second tour des
régionales
et on le voit à la fois sur des enjeux
culturel jadis le mariage dit pour tous
on le voit aujourd'hui sur
l'appréciation du féminisme
on le voit sur des dossiers européens et
en particulier sur la question de l'euro
on le voit également sur les prises de
positions économiques et sociales on
voit bien qu'il ya parfois et bien
plusieurs front national il ya un front
national
plus au nord pas de calais picardie avec
une base très populaire qui parfois se
retrouvent dans des positions
ben oui que le front national peut
partager avec la gauche et parfois la
gauche de la gauche
et puis il ya un front national plus
bourgeois plus classe moyenne qui est
celui de provence alpes côte d'azur par
exemple et qui est sur des positions et
qui sont des positions et bien moins
étatiste moins orienté vers le poids de
la puissance publique dans l'économie
il ya différentes sensibilités ce
séminaire va avoir certainement pour
objectif si c'est possible de parler
d'une seule voix sur ces thèmes où
parfois on entend plusieurs voix voilà
la recherche d'une seule voix donc donc
vous serez à partir de vendredi à ce
second séminaire qui va durer jusqu'à
dimanche je crois que c'est en essonne à
etiolles c'est ça c'est ça j'ai c'est
bien ça ya un ordre du jour défini pour
ce séminaire alors la thématique sait
comment préparer l'arrivée au pouvoir
puisque nous sortons d'élections où
j'entends ce qui a été dit mais malgré
tout il faut rappeler qu on a battu
notre record en pourcentage et en nombre
de voix historique et nous sommes en
progression constante le seul parti en
dynamique dans la vie politique
française
aujourd'hui donc l'idée c'est de comment
faire mieux comment faire mieux
et pour arriver préparer cette accession
au pouvoir et après ou une organisation
des quelques demi-journées il ya une
audition aussi de deux personnalités qui
sont des compagnons de route et condom
on aimerait avoir le lavis l'opinion
d'accord donc ça on va y venir
vous dites on va préparer l'arrivée au
pouvoir du coup on comprend pas très
bien est ce que c'est pour préparer
l'arrivée au pouvoir c'est à dire là
prêt mais 2017 si vous arriviez au
pouvoir ou est-ce que c'est comment
faire en sorte d'accéder à l'elysée
non non c'est pour préparer sur les
cette période 2016 2017
le marine le pen a fait le choix d'une
année sur le terrain rencontre des
français prendre son temps pas des
déplacements à toute vitesse mais
vraiment dollars avec des professionnels
rien mais vous la verrez régulièrement
et puis surtout je pense qu'elle veut
s'échapper du buzz parisien médiatique
permanent partir vers le bas je crois le
débat chez nous c'est pour nouveaux
auditeurs vous vous êtes une émission on
a le temps on parle du fond donc c'est
pas vous que du tout quand on visera en
1er mai mais pour le coup parfois ya
voilà on est la politique on n'est pas
cela la politique c'est aussi d'aller
voir les matériels et son fils c'est
parce qu'on a on a parlé il viendra en
2017 est allé à une conduite extrêmement
sérieuse tout le monde le sait pour la
présidence de la république avec non
plus sérieuse alors qu'on doit chanter
séminaire on a dit que c'était la remise
en cause des thèses que vous vous avez
imposé au front national en oeuvre
notamment moi je suis très favorable à
ce séminaire
je serai sur le nom positif que le fonds
puisse débattre de lui faire son
introspection et vous allez vous allez
pas changer radicalement de vendredi à
dimanche midi
il n'ya pas y avoir de changement
radical vous n'allez pas passer de la
sortie de l'euro à l'euro c'est
formidable je n'en dise non c'est pas un
seigneur programmatique c'est un
séminaire de stratégie de discussions de
débats
c'est plus sur la communication que sur
le fond en fait le front national c'est
un parti qui défend quelques grands
principes qui sont évidemment intangible
qui nous différencie du reste de la
classe politique française nous sommes
pour la souveraineté nationale donc la
démocratie un jeu c'est la même chose
nous sommes pour le l'identité nationale
et et nous considérons que la france la
nation est un modèle extrêmement
performant pour assurer la prospérité la
sécurité la liberté voilà ce que nous
disons à partir de là tout découle et
découle de cela on aurait vraiment
cohérent bas l'euro c'est la
souveraineté économique c'est la
souveraineté monétaire c'est ce qui nous
rend immédiatement la compétitivité par
rapport à l'allemagne d'avoir une
monnaie nationale
c'est ce qui permet financer les pme qui
souffrent aujourd'hui d'un déficit de
financement bancaire extrêmement
important d'avoir comme l'immense
majorité des pays du monde mais là vous
êtes un quinze de réseauter les
arguments d'abord immobilisé pour
convaincre certains des volants mais
c'est nasa c'est le projet sur les îles
je présente les convainc tout le monde
est souverainiste et patriotes au front
national après qu'on sorte moi j'entends
parfois le creuser économique il est
jean temps il ya les étatistes les
libéraux non ça c'est de l'idéologie
il est pragmatique je vous résume en une
phrase c'est la liberté d'entreprendre
avec une intervention de l'état
suffisamment forte pour effectivement
orienter des filières industrielles
organiser une réindustrialisation
innovantes et permettre et bien le
développement de l'emploi voilà ce que
nous visons vous auriez été là en 2012
auriez dit programme économique du front
c'est la sortie de l'euro pour retrouver
les libertés les pouvoirs de la france
et pouvoir essayer de rétablir
l'économie vous auriez fait de ce point
là le point central mais c'est un point
extrêmement important sans monnaies tous
ceux qui vous disent regardez
l'expérience series à tous ceux qui vous
disent on va tout changer sans rien
changer notamment sans changer la
question de l'euro que nous sommes et
menteur on peut pas sortir de
l'austérité c'est à dire la baisse des
salaires la baisse des retraites
la disparition des services publics la
hausse des taxes la hausse des charges
le sens liberté monétaire donc sans
monnaies nationales
mais il n'ya pas que ça y'a le
protectionnisme intelligent ya le
patriotisme économique moi je voudrais
une loi qui favorise aux petites
entreprises dans les marchés publics
comme cela existe aux états unis ou au
canada mais c'est interdit par l'union
peine et à côté cela là comment on fait
pour réduire les délais de paiement pour
les pme qui en souffrent comment on fait
pour les problèmes de trésorerie pour
leurs charges etc
eh bien on a besoin de se relancer cette
activité économique il ya ces points je
vous aurais dit la même chose mais c'est
bien à la limite c'est pas mal ce débat
parce que ça permet de remettre les
points sur les i et ceux qui découvrent
aujourd'hui que nous avons un projet
économique est beaucoup plus globale que
ce qu'on a pu croire manière
caricaturale
c'est plutôt une bonne chose il ya ce
point donc programmatique et puis aussi
des points un peu d'image sondage après
sondage marine le pen reste la
personnalité au classement au palmarès
des personnalités les plus rejetée par
les français elle est constamment en
tête parfois ex-aequo récemment avec
nicolas sarkozy mais constamment en tête
est ce qu'il ya un travail à faire là
dessus pour que vous puissiez dépasser
les 50%
elle est alors en même temps en
parallèle souvent beaucoup de bonnes
opinions
oui mais là
à 50% encore mais le front est victime
plus que d'autres mouvements mais bon je
parvenir vous jouer les victimes non je
vais te regarder la télévision ou lire
les journaux
plus que d'autres mouvements d'une
diabolisation d'une caricature de ses
thèses
ar il faut lutter contre ça moi je pense
qu'un des grands enjeux effectivement du
second tour les second tour pourquoi il
ya des gens qui se mobilisent contre
nous au second tour qui se lèvent le
matin le dimanche du second tout en
disant je vais aller voter contre le
front national
mais moi je vais croiser bonne foi façon
dont on a tous déjà rencontré beaucoup à
vous les comprenez je peux parfois les
comprendre parce que parce qu'ils
croient des choses qui moi aussi
m'inquièterais si elles étaient vraies
sauf qu'elles sont pas vraies elles ne
sont pas vraies il croire et ces
personnes peuvent croire par exemple que
nous allons créer du conflit de la
tension de la guerre civile comme a dit
manuel valls dans la société française
or moi j'affirme et je le démontre que
nous sommes un facteur de pacification
et d'apaisement dans la société
française parce que nous on ne fait pas
de distinction entre les français
on met le contre le communautarisme et
cela le l'antidote au communautarisme
c'est évidemment la paix civile
de la même manière on est contre le
laxisme et le lac simon sait où ça mène
ça mène à ce que les gens se fassent
justice eux-mêmes et ça c'est le début
de la guerre civile
donc quand on est pour l'autorité contre
le laxisme on est pour la pacification
sens mais aussi des français et ce que
les gens en original qui pensent qu'on
va réduire leur liberté voilà ils ont
des idées fausses en tête je les
trouvais que la loi sur le renseignement
et ce n'était pas forcément une position
facile qu'on a eu et pourtant on a tenu
bon au nom des libertés individuelles et
nous sommes extrêmement favorable pas
défendre les libertés de chacun et
chacune qui sont menacés par différentes
causes quand marine le pen a pris la
parole sur les femmes agressées à
cologne elle s'est battue pour les
droits des salles de nouveaux
l'émancipation des vous l'homme c'est un
sujet important de nouveaux thèmes de
2016 l'ajustement la seule la france
apaisée c'est ce qu'il ya sur vos
affiches
fin décembre il ya eu une controverse
avec rmc elle a fait des tweets ou l
comment dire ll
tous étaient des images de victimes de
des 110 ans le dhc ça voilà les
horribles images de décapitation
relevant de la propagande de voilà je
crois qu'elle s'en mord les doigts
elle a été vivement critiqué pour ça et
parfois même au sein du front national
c'était quelque chose qu'il faut arié
arrêté en 2016 ce qu'il fallait arrêter
surtout c'était l'infâme comparaison qui
était faite entre le front national et
donc ses électeurs comme le jour à ce
coup là lors de truites ne cadrait pas
avec l'idée de l'évier licence apaiser
le mot d'ordre ce qui est extrêmement
choquant c'est qu'on entende sur une
grande antenne est mal ailleurs ça
commençait à tout bruit courait bon
front national égale dèche électeurs du
front égale djihadistes mais c'est juste
un gilles porte gilles kepel défend une
thèse plus subtiles nuances et on parle
de communauté d'esprit etc tout cela
s'appelle de l'amalgamé et je crois que
nous devons tous lutter contre les
amalgames
le padd amalgame c'est un grand le
slogan 2015 il doit s'adapter et
s'applique à tout le monde donc mais
donc ça a été efficace je constate
l'efficacité de ce qu'a fait marrer le
vans elle ne l'a pas fait plaisir bien
sûr mais il se trouve que non plus s'il
se trouve que je suis encore plus cette
comparaison depuis qu'elle l'a fait ce
qui prouve l'efficacité
alors oui ça a été a été dommageable
aussi pour pour ça la perception qu'ont
les français je pense que ce bruit ainsi
lieu était infiniment plus dommageable
au front national et surtout à la
dignité nos électeurs donc pourrait leur
dire allez donc la rayer d'atteindre les
50% vous avez séminaire ce week-end et
il y aura vous avez dit l'audition de
personnalités amies donc sur à robert
ménard c'est ça qui sera qui sera là ce
week-end est ce que free ne l'est pas
des tensions dans sa ville semble-t-il
quand même vous dites la france apaisée
mais je me suis ménard on sent qu'il ya
beaucoup de tension enfin maintenant il
ya souvent des noms non des polémiques
on essaie de créer depuis paris dans sa
ville il est plébiscité par les
élections intermédiaires très
massivement il a baissé je crois qu'il
arrive au niveau de fiscalité de 1995
d'accord d'accord mais voilà on y est un
moulin je crois que c'est même lui qui a
fait la république sur son initiative
qui prouve et locales
voilà il ya des levées
le bouclier de personnes diverse et
parfois si chaque ville ça on vous avez
la petite association de 7 8 personnes
qui trouvera des relais très facilement
dans les médias notamment l'idée d'une
grâce au petit bar ouf
son petit bruit à chaque fois que le
front prend une décision mais il se
trouve moi je vous savez le seul critère
qui m'intéresse c'est pas les rédactions
de presse parisienne c'est pas la petite
association de 5,6 militants là sur
glace et le vote des électeurs et se
trouve que le vote il est massivement
derrière lui et il est massivement
derrière nos mères dans l'ensemble des
communes d'ailleurs on progresse
d'élections en élections locales qui par
exemple a retoqué son idée d'une garde
biterroise en disant que ça
correspondait pas forcément cette gtc
son projet je ne sais pas si moi je
l'aurais fait mais ce que son projet de
gens volontaires non armés
ça n'a rien d'extraordinaire donc celle
en voilà que c'est une décision
politique robert ménard sera là ce
week-end
philippe de villiers sera là où il a
échoué après une annonce va presser pas
prévu il ferait partie des personnes que
vous souhaiteriez voir rejoindre le
front national
enfin houleux le grand rassemblement de
philippe de villiers moi je j'ai cru
comprendre qu'aujourd'hui il était
écrivain part il a une voix qui est
intéressante
il intervient dans le débat par ce biais
c'est ce qui semble avoir dit moi je ne
souhaite pas faire de politique
après ce qu'il souhaitera en faire plus
tard je n'en sais strictement rien
il a eu le courage en tout cas de ses
convictions pendant des années des
années qu'ils sont toujours les mêmes
évidemment notamment son grand combat
contre la supranationalité contre
maastricht et en cela il a été une
grande voix des années 90 il ya donc
philippe de villiers qui pour l'instant
n'a pas l'air d'être voilà d'être de
vouloir s'allier à vous nicolas dupont
aignan négligez pas là pour faire de la
politique je crois
il laisse entendre que peut-être il
pourrait revenir nicholas du qu'on verra
d'exclus chevénement a toujours exclu le
ps ait des républicains on n'en parle
pas vous pensé quand même pouvoir gagner
pas demandeur je vais 2017 le ps et les
républicains on n'ait pas demandé un
modèle dit c'est là que vous alliez à
part des petits partis qui gravitent
dans la galaxie du front national vous
savez faisable on progresse on progresse
on progresse la question c'est eux qui
sont obligés de s'allier et même de
faire la moindre alliance ump est non
mais ils sont obligés de ils sont
acculés à cela pour espérer l'emporter
on l'a vu aux régionales ter dans deux
régions et nîmes
continuer la perdre et ça c'est à temps
les accule à soit renoncer à avoir des
élus ce qui quand même particulier la
conception du ps aujourd'hui est
particulière c'est un parti politique
qui renonce à avoir des élus qui renonce
à se présenter aux élections
c'est tout à fait particulier mais il
s'agit donne un petit coup de main elle
m'a répondu à la question combien on est
loin je vous savez très bien qu'on on a
des cadres le court nahd et des
personnalités locales qui arrivent tous
les jours quasiment vient vous le sait
pas forcément des têtes d'affiché vous
connaissez mais est ce que c'est ce
qu'on vit en appartement de discussion
avec le centre nous avons dit nous avons
des collectifs sociaux professionnels
qui chaque jour font venir des nouveaux
profils des chefs d'entreprise des
universitaires des chercheurs des
médecins vers ça c'est intéressant des
avocats nous avons une capacité de
traction extrêmement fort dans la
population française
on tend la main à tous les patriotes de
gauche et de droite on a tendu la main
moi j'ai tendu la main je ne sais
combien de fois à monsieur dupont-aignan
oui sauf que j'ai fini 79 ans devrait
venir parce que j'ai fini par comprendre
qu'il voulait à tout prix être candidat
à la présidentielle en 2017
et donc il ne pourrait rien faire il est
dans une aventure personnelle ben je
vous le dis je le regrette je vous le
dis très clairement je le regrette
profondément parce que je pense que
l'union des patriotes est absolument à
leur risque et le front national doit
changer de nom tout simplement pour se
débarrasser de l'image que vous évoquez
vous dit qu'on fait des procès
d'intention
faut-il changer de nom besoin ou n'ont
jamais autant de changer de nom je n'ai
pas d'opinion n'ai pas d'opinion
j'arrive à être entendu si tu te
rapproches bois d'oeuvre at-elle quitté
la mairie sujet premier bon est-ce que
marine le pen devrait quitter la
présidence du front national lors de la
campagne
est ce que c'est le respect des options
dont vous laisser paître les options oui
ou non on peut discuter de tout il est
évident qu'elle n'est plus
je compte aller quand on est candidat à
la présidentielle petit et c'est la
personnalité avant le parti après ce
qu'elle doit quitter ou pas les
résidentes sur la table il est resté
président du mouvement 2012 ça n'a posé
de problème à personne mais les toutes
dernières questions sur la grande
bretagne sais pas si c'est un modèle
pour vous en tous les cas je ne parle
pas du bric site mais des négociations
ça brille mais je vous parle des
négociations pour l'éviter du règlement
avec david cameron qui est qui qui
négocie à bruxelles des aménagements sur
la souveraineté
oui mais je pense que monsieur cameron
en fait il fait ce gouvernement
européiste qui fait ce référendum contre
1 parce qu'il ya une forte demande au
royaume uni et alors que nous nous
proposons ce référendum aussi sur
l'appartenance à l'union européenne
précédé de négociations mais nous
serions un goût
demande patriotes qui ferait
volontairement ce référendum ce qui est
tout à fait différent donc me gêne un
sentiment conséquemment les entretiens
de fausses négociations pour éviter à
tout prix que les britanniques votent le
bret exit la sortie de l'union de
l'union européenne et bien moi j'espère
qu'ils voteront la sortie de l'union
européenne parce que il n'a obtenu que
de très maigres vous avancez monsieur
cameron aujourd'hui est donc et donc il
ne peut pas présenter cela comme une
avancée majeure
j'encourage nos amis patriotes
britannique a voté la sortie de l'union
européenne et j'espère que nous aurons
nous aussi notre france exit où notre
président je sais pas comment on doit
dire c'est à dire un référendum en
france sur cette question majeure
démocratique rien sic et que ramires aux
écuries terre et j'essaie l'union
rotation de montres pack finalement le
seul moyen pour vous de faire ce que
voulait faire c'est de sortir l'union
européenne que c'est le chemin auquel
vous devrait aboutir
quand les négociations sont sincères par
un gouvernement déterminé
elles peuvent peut-être aboutir et si
elles n'aboutissent pas si la machine
est effectivement irréformable alors on
fera le choix de la sortie merci merci à
vous messieurs bonsoir à tous et à très
vite merci
i